on voit cette réflexion en termes de
rhétorique le ministre de la défense
l'ukrainien lui n'a pas hésité à
qualifier ce matin la demi-heure poutine
de d'hitler des temps modernes zelensky
donc venu chercher hier le soutien des
américains joe biden on le sent beaucoup
moins réservé lorsqu'on les interroge
sur les actes de vladimir poutine alors
que de nombreux dirigeants on le sait on
prenne beaucoup de distance et renvoie
régulièrement la balle à la justice
internationale
lui a décidé hier de franchir un cap on
va l'écouter et puis on y revient juste
après
oui je pense que c'est un criminel de
guerre
voilà c'est une séquence qui étaient
filmées donc assez rapidement à
washington joe biden est interpellé par
la presse et donc il qualifie vladimir
poutine de criminels de guerre bien de
l'entendre c'est un qualificatif
évidemment qui n'a pas plu au kremlin
cette question elle se pose chaque jour
mais elle se renforce même et encore
plus après cette nouvelle attaque contre
un un théâtre de marée de mario folie
oui puis surtout quand elle est incarnée
par un président américain en fonction
et c'est vrai qu'il a hésité une seconde
avant d'utiliser le terme criminels de
guerre ensuite il l'a redit et on voit
qu'on est en train de monter à chaque
fois sur un étage supplémentaire dans la
dans la négociation entre les uns et des
autres hier c'était aussi vladimir
poutine qui faisait allusion à la
seconde guerre mondiale en parlant de
pogroms en disant finalement les russes
aujourd'hui sont victimes de pogroms
comme l'était des juifs dans le temps
quand on les sanctionne quand on
sanctionne aussi la musique quand on
sanctionne aussi les scientifiques quand
on sanctionne les sportifs et tout ce
qui va avec on se retrouve à ce niveau
de détestation qui est assez rare mais
qui est assez dangereux finalement est
ce qui pousse en fait les uns et les
autres extrême alors aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que qualifié vladimir poutine de
crimes de guerre avec la guerre en
ukraine ça veut dire qu'il ya des faits
effectivement pour étayer cette
accusation et que ce qui est en train de
se passer à marioupol on l'avait déjà vu
dans d'autres villes on pense évidemment
la syrie mais là on est sur le
territoire européen on voit des
bombardements et c'est vrai que du coup
ça amène à devoir aller soit vers une
cour pénale internationale soit comme ça
n'a pas été signé imaginer construire un
tribunal de guerre merci beaucoup
armelle pour le décryptage sachez que la
france a salué un ce matin là la
décision rendue précisément hier par la
cour internationale de justice la cj qui
ordonne à la russie d'arrêter son
invasion de l'ukraine